los miembros del capitolio aseguran está
cerca de acordar la madre de todas las
sanciones contra moscú el proyecto de
ley podría dirigirse a los bancos rusos
y a la deuda nacional y podría
proporcionar más ayuda militar a ucrania
el razonamiento de washington rusia ha
concentrado unos 100.000 soldados cerca
de la frontera ucraniana por lo que la
embajadora de estados unidos en naciones
unidas quiere presionar a rusia
los rusos han acumulado 100.000 soldados
a lo largo de la frontera han trasladado
tropas a belarús han continuado la
escalada a pesar de nuestros esfuerzos
por encontrar una vía diplomática para
ellos
el primer ministro de reino unido boris
johnson pidió a rusia seguir con las
negociaciones para rebajar las tensiones
pero moscú tiene sus propias exigencias
en materia de seguridad que occidente
prometa que ucrania nunca entrará en la
otan y que la alianza retire sus tropas
y armas de europa del este como
ahora sabemos el coste de las palabras
de occidente no se buscará no sólo
promesas y compro los políticos sino
garantías de seguridad jurídicamente
vinculantes que respondan a la seguridad
en todo el continente europeo con plena
e igual consideración de los intereses
legítimos de rusia misterioso phrazes
que filtró el viernes el presidente de
ucrania volodymyr selenski instó a los
socios occidentales a evitar fomentar el
pánico de una posible invasión sin
embargo lleva ha insistido en la
importancia de ser firmes en las
negociaciones